The first thing you need to analyze is,
is your company ready for change?
Is your company willing to look
at new ways of doing things?
>> This program, transformational
leadership, was designed specifically for
us to think about how do we pivot
the organization, how do we shift the way
that we think as an organization so
that we can create an organization that
is more poised to positively disrupt
itself in the landscape of disruption.
[MUSIC]
>> When a company or an organization
comes to campus to work with us,
we've designed the content to meet their
needs in a very human centered way.
>> So we are trying to drive innovation,
we're trying to focus
on the future trends.
And the whole program is customized
in a way that works for us.
>> The faculty director works very very
closely with the client to determine what
the content is going to be in the program,
who's going to teach in the program and
what other kinds of added
benefits there might be.
>> They want to really make sure
what we're trying to achieve and
then find the right faculty
to fill those spots for us.
>> The introduction to the d.school,
they got this
wonderful way of bringing it all together,
getting you to be able to prototype,
being able to learn the principles of
Silicon Valley about failing fast and
then amplifying what really works.
>> The amount of information that faculty
can condense in an 80-minute session and
the relevancy to what we do day to day
is essential and it happens every time.
>> They are not theoretical and just
let's talk about what's in the book but
they make it practical,
they make it actionable.
>> In most of our programs, there's
the blend of different kinds of learning.
So we may have some case studies,
we may have simulations,
we may have experiential activities and
also a set of online assets that can be
used in a blended program or can be used
in a fully online program for companies.
>> We have 12 different organizations
within our company coming to this program,
making those networks and connections.
>> We have now developed a common
language across the organization.
>> I know it might sound like a cliche,
but
we don't think that you can afford not
to do the Stanford customized program.
>> This program is helping
us transform our company
the way we want to be at a faster pace.
>> The thing I love about Stanford and
the thing that was so
appealing to us about Stanford is,
you've got a faculty and
staff who is focused on actually
making a difference in the world.
[MUSIC]